you have so much going on uh we'll get
to the bsf album that's coming out soon
uh
but
is there ever going to be the conway
benny tape
man i hope so i hope so he i got room
for it i don't know he won't have room
for when he finished i'm saying i know
you guys got [ __ ] busy schedules
you're running a label you talk about
he's running a label we talk about it
all the time even like
uh planning on starting it
i think we probably even started i think
it's maybe a song or two somewhere for
it gotta be like six songs that's it six
to eight records man that's all i gotta
be that's all i got to be maybe
something light bro just throw it out
there something light man i think we
should just do it and just throw it out
as like a mixtape just me and him no
distributors there's no nothing straight
up and then [ __ ] do like a collab
merch the merch will go craz man if you
guys
march will go crazy
real [ __ ] it's a half a million dollar
merch drop well that's a fact million
million
million dollar merge drop but that's
something that we got to do man then we
just clearing this [ __ ] up but that just
that just leaves something
that's just another box we could check
off